hi everyone
I hope you had a great lunch so let's
get started this talk is about
augmenting empathy and what I mean by
that is basically that you already have
empty but there can be some things or
some tools that you use to actually
augment that a little bit more to
understand some situations and to make
things a little bit more clear so we'll
be using CSS SVG and WebRTC to do this
so let's see my name is Frank
I work as accessibility innovation and
research head of it at barrierbreak
basically what this means is I do a lot
of R&D to try to look at new
technologies and using existing
technologies and new ways to basically
help people with disabilities
I'm also credited of the HTML spec at
the WCC and a few other WC groups
previously I used to work at opera at
barrierbreak
it's it's a company based in Mumbai and
it does a lot of work in consulting
accessibility consulting auditing and
stuff like that but it's also an
enterprise with a social mission and
part of that mission is providing
opportunities to people with
disabilities and so much so that about
70 percent of our staff are people with
disabilities
one of those people and the stuff is a
person named Amit he was born with low
vision and we got together get to know
each other when I joined barrierbreak
and back in about 2005 he had met with
an accident and he lost sight in his
right eye so but that didn't stop him
he still had an interest in tech and he
ended up becoming a trainer and goes to
a lot of different conferences trainings
and workshops to actually teach people
how to make their sites accessible now
when I got to know him and we got
talking they were I quickly realized
that there were a lot of things which
people who didn't have low vision were
confused about especially with it with
his condition because a lot of times
people just couldn't understand the way
in which his vision worked or didn't
work very big also had a lot of other
people who were low vision so I talked
with them as well and at certain times I
talked with their colleagues some of
them their friends and their families
and caretakers as well and one trend
basically kept coming again and again
which was a lot of times it was very
difficult for people with low vision to
really articulate what their condition
was how or how they basically saw the
world and sometimes people with people
who didn't have low vision just couldn't
understand what was happening so I did a
little bit more research I actually
consulted an ophthalmologist as well to
get a medical perspective and a
perspective of a person who has dealt
with hundreds or thousands of such cases
and one thing was very very clear low
vision is a very generic term right so
if you say someone has low vision a lot
of times people assume that it's just a
severe form of myopia a severe form of
shortsightedness that can be the case
but that's not always the case sometimes
you have glaucoma retinitis pigmentosa
macular degeneration all these things
are there and if you ask the random
person on the street
okay what's macular degeneration they
might not know so one thing became clear
that
one of the things that I could do is not
to help people with low vision but
actually help everyone else understand
what low vision is and that's where the
simulators come in so I said okay can we
make something to simulate what their
vision is like and if it is possible can
we use the web to do this and also gravy
on top if we can use JavaScript less and
SVG and CSS more then that'll be even
more awesome so the first condition that
I chose was colorblindness and this is
even more of pointing over here in
Europe because about 8% of men and about
0.5% of women of northern European
ancestry have some form of red-green
color blindness and it's it's you know
in the more you talk to people who have
red-green color blindness the more
you'll see that in the physical world
are not just in the online world but in
the physical world there's still a lot
of stuff in which you need to determine
whether something is red or green right
the most obvious example is traffic
lights but that's just not the case
there are other small cases as well for
example if you have the MacBook Charger
right
you see if you charge it and if you want
to look from afar but there is still
charging or it has a charge the only way
to distinguish it is whether it's red or
green in color that's it so I made a
tool which you can actually simulate
different conditions this is just using
WebRTC and then applying SVG on top and
the reason why it's actually pretty
useful is because a lot of times people
get it wrong if you ask I've asked a lot
of people who have just everyday normal
20/20 vision what it'd be like if
someone has red-green color blindness
and see something which is red in color
what what would they see and a lot of
things people become kind of confused
they don't know a lot of times people
just assume that it'll be like a
desaturated version of that of that
image but that's not the case over here
we can see that you know in in one
condition proto normally you'll have
this bench as brown
in color on the other hand you'll have
something which is like greenish in
color the real color is actually red
right so how do we actually do this I
use something called Fe color matrix SVG
Fe color matrix F V stands for filter
effects and the color matrix is
basically a set of matrix values that
you provide so it basically works like
this so you have an image each and every
image will have an RGB a value now you
have a matrix with a set of values over
here and all you do is matrix multiply
all those values together to form a new
color for that particular pixel you can
define an SVG color filter over here
color matrix filter so you can just say
in the SVG you can say F filter ID is
equal to whatever and then Fe color
matrix type is equal to matrix and
values you can write out all the values
comma-separated in the CSS it's as
simple as saying filter URL hashtag
whatever so that's all very very nice to
know right but it's one thing to have an
academic or mathematical perspective of
how SVG color matrix works and the other
is to have an intuitive understanding
and the only thing that I have seen
which in which grants you that is
experimentation unfortunately you just
can't get it you know how it works just
by learning a few things you need to
experiment fortunately if you can just
Google you have SVG filter playground
it's a very very nice resource where you
can mix and match different values and
see what the output would be and that
gives a better person and a more
intuitive understanding of the color
matrix I'll be sharing these slides
later on as well with links to some
really really nice articles on a few
color matrix so let's take this
opportunity to know about F the color
matrix and put it in our pocket we'll
revisit this later on so now that we
have a tool which can address different
color blindness condition
one of the things that I also realized
when when when talking with people with
red-green color blindness is well how do
you distinguish between red and green
and nothing else it's it's a bit
difficult to do so so I made something
which for lack of a better name I just
called the red-green color sieve under
on the left you have the you know one
example of a Ishihara test which is
generally a set of tests which is used
by people to diagnose color blindness so
if you don't have color blindness for
example over here you'll see something
like 74 but if you do have color
blindness you might see something like
21 so over here let me just go back so
over here you can see that I've made
something where you're basically
isolating things into two categories if
something is red it goes into the left
category if something is right if
something is green then it goes into the
other category this is all done in real
time and it's all done using basically
CSS and SVG the the only JavaScript part
is actually getting the camera output so
this is how we do it the first thing
that we do is apply a SVG filter and the
second thing we do is apply a mixed
blend mode of hue very simple but in
highs a lot of complexity behind it and
let's revisit this let's let's see and
go into a deeper dive into what this all
means and how this effect is actually
done so to do that let's go really
really back how many people watched
Looney Tunes when they were channeled
everyone Wow everyone so all these kind
of cartoons actually use something
called cel animation cel stood for
cellulose celluloid and and the reason
why is because these were basically
transparent sheets and generally
speaking in any any kind of animation
you had a you know a bunch of characters
which we're moving around but you also
had some background which was static
right so what you could do is basically
have a sheet where you just paint the
background once and
be done with it and then all the other
stuff you can just do with the character
and animations and put one layer on top
so a lot of these animations were done
like this where the character animations
were done by one team and then the
background animation or background
painting was done by some other team in
parallel and then the final result was
basically just putting those layers on
top of each other so this was basically
an early form of what we call composting
so composting and blending there respect
for it as well the CSS blend mode
suspect is based off this but
compositing and blending has been there
for a long long time even as part of SVG
so what exactly is compositing it's
basically how to deal with overlapping
objects right so overall compositing is
quartered of compositing plus blending
but what exactly is Porter does
compositing it's it's big named after a
Thomas Burton and Tom Duff who in the
early eighties I think 1984 they
published a seminal paper on how to deal
with overlapping objects this exact
thing called compositing at that time
they were in the early 80s they were
working together on a small company
called Lucasfilm which was doing a lot
of pioneering work when it came to
digital graphics and basically what they
said was in that paper that if you have
two layers one on top of the other right
so the top layer is called a source
layer the bottom layer is called the
destination right so in that overlapped
portion you can do pretty much four
things first
none you don't do anything you don't
show anything over there second is the
source in which is sure the top layer
third is the destination which you show
the bottom layer and the fourth and more
more interesting one is show a
combination of both the top and the
bottom layer right and this is where you
know a pasty and alpha channels come in
so coming back to our example what we
need to do in the first half to recreate
the effect that we saw in the color
sieve is to somehow make it black and
white but only the red color shown so in
this case what we do is if you can see
the red green
and blue channels are all zero right so
what in effect what this matrix is doing
is basically taking this image and
making everything of transparent except
for the colors which have a little bit
of an R value then we composite it on
top of the original image to get some of
the red stuff then what we do is we take
another image and it over here we're
doing a fickle our matrix type is equal
to saturate value is equal to zero so
it's totally d saturated and then we
composite them on top to get the black
and white image with just the red
showing all of this using just SVG
nothing else so now the first part is
complete the second thing we want to do
is to understand blending and how that
works so blending is basically how to
deal with the overlapped portion in
terms of colors and the mixing of the
colors so for example you have this
particular layer and then you have a
layer on top of it over here so there's
a portion which is overlapping right how
do we deal with the colors over here
right that's the essence of blending so
in a more practical example let's see
this image and if you want to create
recreate this image we can have a few
layers we can mix and match them to
whatever blend one that we want to
achieve this particular final layer so
this is essentially what blending is
mixing and matching different layers to
achieve a final effect so let's come
back to an example over here we have a
container div which is red in color
inside this we have the video which is
running right now we haven't really
applied any effect so it's just normal
colors the moment we apply a SVG filter
that we talked about everything is
grayscale apart from the red stuff then
we'll apply a blend mode in this case
what we're doing is applying a hue gen
mode this works in the HSL space so what
it will do is it will take the hue from
the top layer
and combine it with the saturation and
luminosity of the bottom layer so in
this case all of the black and white
stuff will just be basically a whole big
gray area whereas the red stuff will be
just very brightly red so ultimately you
get this right so it's just two lines
but it hides a lot of complexity but
it's very very important to know the the
concept of layers and how it plays into
blending and compositing and what all
you can do without but just JavaScript
if you just have a proper understanding
of it one more thing that I worked on
was macular degeneration sometimes it's
also called aids related macular
degeneration and often results in blood
or no vision in the central field it's
pretty hard to sometimes explain this
but if you have a visual then you will
see what it actually means it's
sometimes also pretty tragic or hard
work heartbreaking because a lot of
times it affects people who are older
and by the time they have grandchildren
and sometimes it they have very hard
time actually seeing the faces of their
grandchildren and that's yeah that's and
that's something which if someone else
comes in that's something which people
don't get the the human aspect of how it
makes people feel so anyways if I like I
was saying if I have to recreate this
effect using CSS and SVG or just SVG or
just CSS how do I do this fortunately in
this case I don't even want to use SVG I
can just use a radial gradient with a
blend mode and the way I do it is be
based on this so if you have a container
div which is a radial gradient which is
basically just black to transparent and
you combine it with the video output and
then you apply a mix blend mode to
multiply you get this kind of effect
right in most cases in most web designs
you won't really want to use this but if
you take the opposite of it in which you
have transparent - black radial gradient
and you combine it with an image
then apply a multiply blend mode then
you can get some really nice effects on
images without using Photoshop which is
really really great one more thing that
I wanted for all these simulators to do
is for you to actually put it on top of
VR headsets nowadays VR headsets I can
in cheap and some of these actually
allow for you to use the back camera to
see on the other side not all of them
but some of them actually allow you to
do that so if you do then you can
actually do this
you can ask stare scopic mode where
basically you're having two video
elements and then you can also go
fullscreen
and you know use it as part of a VR to
get a more immersive experience now the
thing is if you want to do this right
there are a few things that you want to
do first you want to make sure that it
displays just one video on portrait mode
and two videos on landscape mode so you
have to first detect whether if
something is in portrait mode and hide
the video so it it there's a lot of
stuff which is going on over here I also
want to make sure that everything is
full screen so that you don't see the
browser address bar and once you're
actually in that full-screen mode you
don't want to switch between portrait
and landscape every time you're moving
your head so you want to lock the
orientation as well so this is how we do
it you you can have a full screen API
the moment something calls in full
screen you can use the orientation lock
API to lock the orientation so that it
doesn't switch between portrait and
landscape all the time one more thing
that I do is I use CSS exclusively for
fullscreen as well so in this case I can
use along with prefixes of course the
fullscreen pseudo-element this will just
be applied on fullscreen one more thing
that I do is of course have custom CSS
for the orientation so if something is
in portrait mode it needs to have
certain set of Styles applied and
something is in landscape mode it needs
something different and over here you
can have the media queries for
orientation landscape as well another
thing that I have seen that not a lot of
people are talking about but they should
is
the fact that in pwace you have a lot of
display modes right so you can load a
PWA as a normal browser tab right but
once you install that PWA you can open
up as a normal standalone app right and
in that case what happens is you don't
have the the browser address bar which
means suddenly now have increased screen
real-estate that you need to account for
that you need to do something with right
and over here you can use the display
mode standalone or just basically just
see what the display mode is and
depending upon that you can have custom
CSS to account for that that's also one
of the things that I've used and one
last thing that I'll leave you with is
that none of this actually matters if
you don't actually talk with people and
interact with people with real
disabilities that's really really
important I like this tweet which was
says you know I want to see something
read we do if you're disabled and being
told you're an inspiration and the
person told you didn't stick around to
get to know and get to know you as a
person which is really true it got like
632 retweets by the time I screenshot at
this and yeah that's a that's a big big
thing like when you're talking about
empathy you really need to you know
generate empty somehow and the only way
in which you can do it is to actually be
someone's friend or actually be
listening to a person not just
academically being things here and there
right and that's one of the things about
disability simulators a lot of people
think that just because I have have
interacted with the simulators suddenly
I know everything about people with that
particular disability that's not true
human interaction is always always
required a lot of times people who are
able-bodied they put on a simulator they
struggle and then they put it back down
and then they think that everyone with
that disability is just struggling 24/7
that's also wrong this is a tweet which
says you know not every person with the
disability feels they're suffering some
people are
yes but the insulation insinuation that
disability is equal to suffering is able
your Humphrey Legolas expression or be
able know with your thought which is
true okay so when it comes to MT
one one layer is yes you need to think
about what other people are finding
challenging what problems people are
facing but the other side is actually to
get to know what they want to do what
their potential is what what they aim
for what there are what are their goals
in life
and then what are you going to do about
it right so these tools that I try to
make I always kind of force the idea
that ok now actually do a task five
times because by the fifth time they're
not suffer they're they're not
struggling so much then they realize
that okay people who have these
conditions have developed coping
mechanisms and I've actually kind of get
gotten used to it and now that they can
just function that's like and everyone
else
so being empathetic it's according to me
recognizing a few things it's
multi-layered right you need to
recognize the challenges that people
face right and it could be something as
simple as just blaming someone when they
say they have a problem right and it
just doesn't even apply to people with
disabilities but every kind of
marginalized group just listen and
believe them when they say they have a
problem the second thing is recognizing
the strengths and the potential that
people have right so if a person really
wants to do something have faith in them
I can give you a story of a person who
is working in man you break right now
who when she was diagnosed with low
vision a lot of well-meaning
well-wishers just said that okay take a
pottery or take up handicrafts and stuff
like that it was coming from a good
place but it was wasn't the right advice
that person wanted to go in tech that
person wanted to do stuff with computers
fortunately she joined married break and
now she's one of the top people over
there
but the main thing is to recognize that
what other people are supposed to be
doing what what other people are capable
of doing and supporting that and
ultimately your the way in which you
display your entity is has to be a
combination of all these things just
like blend modes just like you have
different layers and you kind of
mix and match between different colors
the same thing has to be happening with
your approach towards emptying as well
so recognize the challenges they face
recognize there are that they are
capable they have potential and then
ultimately your action as well because
empty without action is useless and
that's the thought that I'll leave you
with thank you so much
[Music]